The joe rogan experience
podcast my night day.
It's uh,
it gets real tricky when someone does
denies the rights of citizens than
someone who's empowered.
Denies the rights because w what are you
then,
if you're in power and you're denying
the rights,
as soon as you step in and deny people
do processed,
deny people lawyers to die people,
why would you ever want to do that?
It's a real question.
So when things get passed,
like the National Defense Authorization
Act allows the government to
indefinitely detained American civilians
and they don't have to do anything.
They're not required to notify your
family.
They're not required to arrest you.
They're not required to.
You don't,
you can't,
you don't have to get a lawyer.
They can just lock you up when you see
shit like that.
Does that drive you crazy?
Oh yeah.
And people always say to me,
they say,
well,
you know,
why are you defending the terrorist?
And what you try to explain to people is
without the due process,
there's no confirmation that this is a
terrorist.
The only way you know it's a terrorist
is when some court somewhere determines
upon looking at the evidence that this
person is a terrorist.
Once you can kill somebody on the
suspicion of being a terrorist,
well,
we're all under suspicion of terrorist
under the certain conditions that
someone wants to deem a mistaken
identity situation.
You know?
Or I mean how many,
how many guys are named Omar or Mohammad
or you know what I mean?
Well,
how about in this dorm or case the,
the cop shot up two different cars that
were the wrong cards.
Perfect example.
You the,
the idea that the government should have
special powers that regular human beings
don't.
That's crazy.
Well,
they have that now.
I mean,
I think they already do because
sure.
Take it to the next level and decide
that you're going to deny the rights of
people that you feel are guilty.
Well,
who are you and how do I know that
you're infallible and how do I know that
this isn't corruption?
How do I know this isn't a personal
grudge?
It's not like you're dealing with an
organization that has a spotless record
over the past,
you know,
200 years where they're the most ethical
human beings to ever exist.
And people from other countries come to
them for,
no,
we've caught them a lie,
but $1 million.
Oh,
you had could.
We had a committee hearings,
which you cannot even imagine today,
which shows you how much things have
changed.
In the 1970s we had the church committee
hearings in the Pike Committee hearings
where the government actually on
television exposed everything the CIA
had been doing since the end of the
Second World War.
The assassinations and all this kind of
stuff.
The crown jewels are what the CIA used
to call those secrets that were exposed
on television by congressional and
senatorial committees.
It just shows you what happens when
there's no oversight and if stuff is too
secret to have oversight over,
you're asking for trouble.
There's too many ways human beings can
justify going beyond the rules,
and there's always a good reason and you
hear it today.
I mean,
the waterboarding thing.
As a perfect example,
we prosecuted people at Nuremberg for
having an attitude that we have now,
which is,
hey,
if they're terrorists and you can save
lives by torturing people.
Isn't that an ethical dilemma where it's
worth torturing some guy,
you know,
is bad anyway in order to save lives.
I mean,
if you could have prevented the two
towers from falling down by
waterboarding,
a couple of bad guys,
isn't that worth it?
And that those ethical dilemmas lead you
off into the weeds really quickly.
And history shows that over and over
again.
It's,
it's very doubtful that it's helping
either.
It's very doubtful that you're really
getting that kind of key information
from people by throwing water down their
mouth.
You know,
I don't,
I just,
I don't know if if torturing people gets
them to tell the truth,
gets him to tell you anything you want.
There's an old line about,
would you,
and I wish I could quote it at length.
It's a wonderful line going back
hundreds of years where somebody says,
would you abrogate the laws in order to
get the devil?
And the other guy says,
no,
I would,
I would stick to the laws because if,
if you abrogate the laws to get to the
devil,
you take away the only thing that
protects yourself eventually.
And that's what this is.
People say,
well,
it's okay to go after this to get to
terrorists.
What makes you think one that it'll stay
with terrorists and to that what a
terrorist is,
that definition won't change.
The Bush administration was calling
these people that would light,
you know,
car dealerships on fire in the middle of
the night when there was no one there.
Ecoterrorists you're going to drone
those people,
right?
When are you going to do exactly where
does the line get drawn and who gets to
the
antifungal coffee proponents that might
get a little hyped up,
but those motherfuckers grown those
people.
I mean do this whole fucking pope thing.
To me it's crazy,
crazy and hilarious that we even pay
attention to what that clown is doing.
How is that even making the news?
There's some weird fucking group of
people who do like the most bizarre
ceremonies who I,
I don't sanctioned sanctioned
governments and mass media.
No one calls it a call.
The guy's wearing a fucking wizard out
yet with a fish head hat.
It's if you tried to do that today and
tried to say,
I am a Dorn of God.
He has brought to me this information.
He tried,
you set up a shop,
they would think you are a fucking loon.
But because of the fact that it's been
around for a long time,
this guy has a direct lineage.
We're supposed to take it serious.
We're supposed to take it seriously and
we're supposed to fucking ignore all the
Shit Catholicism did.
Well,
how about this shit here
did he released a priest that had
molested 200 deaf boys,
200 he let them go,
Huh?
He let them go,
brought him into psychiatric instead of
bringing in and getting them prosecuted.
They brought him in for psychiatric
treatment and this guy went on to,
they went to another parish and molested
more voice.
I mean,
it's fucking craziness.
He did that time and time again.
He took people away from being
prosecuted and sent him to psychiatric
care and and they're free.
They're free to go.
They're free.
They're walking around the streets.
Some of them are in these huge religious
retreat places that they have beautiful
grounds and these guys are just
wandering around taking care of for the
rest of their lives and the trauma.
There's a place like that up by where I
live.
Where?
Yeah,
there that.
Yeah.
So right.
So that's happening and they don't pay
taxes.
They don't pay fucking taxes.
That is is
fucking crazy.
All that shit is crazy.
The idea that they should be able to
make golden buildings and not pay taxes.
Bitch,
are you out of your fucking mind?
Can you fucking imagine that's a
business.
It's a business.
It's a fucking business.
You're not.
No.
You don't talk directly directly for
God.
It's 2013 stop.
Stop your bullshit.
You're not telling the truth.
You don't know that much.
I don't believe you.
I think you are very charismatic and
there's a lot of people that want to
believe you and they'll go along with
it.
But you're talking crazy to God's not
talking to you stupid.
No,
you're an asshole.
You're an asshole and you,
you'd taken their money.
And we've got to make sure that this
stops with our generation.
We've got to make sure that future
generations don't,
they don't have a gigantic religious
leader.
Someone who tells them based on some
nutty shit that was written thousands of
years ago by people drew on animal
skins.
Yeah.
So it also,
it spreads that the way that looks with
Catholicism is just one version of the
problem.
The other problem is the guy who calls,
you know,
there's like an,
in the way there was a pope,
there's also a dude who calls himself
the president,
but instead of representing some
phantasmo forest called God,
he says,
I represent the will of the people.
Yet he doesn't really represent the well
of the people.
It doesn't seem like that when he goes
to when,
when,
when they do the polls and that fine as
it turns out,
you know,
and I'm not just the present,
of course the government as a whole,
the president doesn't have to tell
Alterian power,
but I don't think that the president
really represents the will of the
people.
And I don't think Congress represents
the will of the people.
And I don't think Senate represents the
will of the people any more than the
pope represents the will of God.
And I think it's this,
this imaginary thing that we're supposed
to believe in because it makes us feel
more comfortable as those,
these people are really enacting the
will of the people.
I think the will of the people is a,
that we want peace.
We want to be able to,
like we,
we do want security,
we want education,
but we don't want fucking war with Iran.
Yeah,
we don't want fucking war with Iraq,
Iraq,
Iraq.
How the fuck do you say?
And I forget to say that I got,
so start up,
we don't want it.
Nobody wants war.
And if there is,
it's a small faction of people,
sweaty red face.
Cocksuckers
did you guys,
I was going to bring this up yesterday.
Did you guys hear about this guy who got
arrested with a hundred bags of heroin
up his ass?
No hundred bags.
Hundred bags.
It was a traffic stop.
This his ass hauled him is brutal.
Ah,
you have a sinkhole
sir?
It's a hundred bags of heroin,
man.
That's the man.
Oh,
oh Jesus.
Okay.
I,
I look,
I look this killa season.
No,
no,
this one.
Okay.
This guy just had one.
Okay,
let's get the other guy had it.
His ass.
One guy just had 200 bags.
I'm like,
did someone just take it to the next
level?
You gotta you gotta Watch Killa season.
So this dude gets busted on the
palisades parkway.
They pull him over and his 2005
Mitsubishi Lancer and he's acting real
weird.
And um,
so they decided to bring him in.
So they bring him in and they opened up
his ass.
They just gave him a cavity check.
I mean the guy didn't do anything wrong
and they pulled him over.
He just looked weird.
He was tweaking out on his own.
Something was going on with the man.
He was pulled over.
I mean,
routine traffic stop.
But they,
they detected the smell of marijuana and
that's where they,
uh,
that's where they got them and they
brought him in because they smelled
marijuana.
That's it.
And he had a hundred bags of heroin up
his ass.
And you can't put a hundred bags of
heroin up your ass while the cops are
going from their car to your car.
You can't do that.
So he was driving around with those
packed up.
Is that,
why would you drive around and smoke
weed with a hundred packs of heroin in
your ass?
Well,
I think he's just one of those guys.
That's his move.
Maybe it's like,
like Russian chicks would put ben Wa
balls and their pussy to tighten up
their must.
They're fuck muscle.
Maybe this dude was just like exercise
and his,
his ass story.
Starfish,
starfish.
Maybe he didn't trust his roommate's
like,
man,
if I leave,
this is a hundred bags of heroin.
Well these motherfuckers to get itself.
He went to the gym.
He's like,
man,
I can't fit it in my pocket.
I can't leave.
I can't leave it in my dash.
Let's work on that star fish.
The glove box is full.
Hmm.
Maybe I just stuffed this up my ass.
Can I fit a hundred bags?
Well,
let's see.
Five,
six.
Wow.
Am I really going to get 94?
Dr. Steven Greer,
if you don't know who Dr. Greer is,
there's a thing that a lot of people are
aware of that came out was at 20 2011,
the disclosure project,
was it 2001 2011.
I met one I meant right around September
11th,
and that's where the 11 came from my
head.
Um,
2001,
uh,
it was a huge,
in the Internet,
a huge point of controversy and a,
a topic of conversation.
It was you,
uh,
on stage introducing this disclosure
project,
explaining how much information,
uh,
you had,
access to about alien spacecrafts
visiting earth and how many
distinguished high ranking military
people.
And that was where it got shocking,
uh,
agreed with you.
Yeah.
And,
yeah,
one of the interesting thing,
after we put this briefing together for
Clinton and,
uh,
you know,
Laurance Rockefeller,
uh,
I put the concept together,
the best available evidence and all
these cases,
and then Lawrence Rockefeller hosted a
bill and Hillary Clinton at the
Rockefeller ranch,
and that it had me out there shortly
before that.
And Mr Rockefeller was the white hat in
the family who wanted to end the
secrecy,
unlike some of his,
his family.
Uh,
and,
and he,
so he said to me one night,
I was at on,
on his porch,
on a deck in the grand tetons at the
[inaudible] ranch,
and,
and he said,
uh,
we really need you to hurry up and do
this.
And I said,
Oh,
Lawrence,
I'm just a doctor in North Carolina.
I'm working in an er,
you know,
he says,
no,
you have to do it.
I said,
no,
Lawrence,
you have to get these guys to do.
He says,
they will never do it.
And I said,
Lawrence,
for God's sakes,
you're old,
you're rich and you're rockefeller.
And he says,
no.
He says,
the implications of this are so vast.
And so profound that no aspect of life
will be unchanged when it comes out.
I said,
yes,
Lawrence,
that's why it's secret.
And then he said to me,
well,
that means those folks aren't going to
do it.
And then,
you know,
before that,
as shortly after that,
and I had this,
um,
meeting with the CIA director and,
and,
and one of the president's friends came
to my house and this was a very
disturbing story.
I'm sitting at the table with my four
kids,
four daughters,
and this man who's very close friends
with the president,
uh,
Clinton says to me,
um,
well,
you know,
they're very supportive of what you've
recommended in this white patriarch.
I said,
great.
And he says,
but they're not going to do it.
I said,
why not?
He says,
they're convinced that if the president
steps into this too hard,
he'll end up like Jack Kennedy.
And I started laughing,
thinking,
what a load of nonsense.
And he stopped me.
He says,
no,
they're serious.
I said,
well,
don't say this in front of the kids.
So we went to the library in my house,
um,
after dinner,
and I said,
what are you talking about Kevin?
And he said,
they really think this is too dangerous.
I said,
well,
what am I supposed to do?
What am I chop liver?
And he looked at me and he says,
yeah,
you're expendable.
So I've always viewed myself as the kind
of the throwaway guy and all of this.
I'm in the sense that these guys,
you know,
the,
the folks who have enormous political
power and corporate power,
uh,
even the ones who support this very
avidly,
and there's a lot of them,
um,
they don't want to stick their necks
out,
but I'm confused.
Okay.
Why would they kill Bill Clinton if Bill
Clinton came out and said that we may
have evidence that there might be some
intelligent life out there in the world
or universe?
She goes,
you know,
it's like the rem song.
It's the end of the world as we know it.
Because if that,
if that happens when that happens,
people would panic.
No,
no,
no.
The public isn't going to panic over
this unless it's couched in a stupid
way.
Well,
the public definitely will panic if the
president comes out and says,
Ufo is,
and then he gets whacked.
That would lead to panic.
Yeah,
but there's a bigger problem if the
president doesn't have control access
over these projects.
He didn't want to talk about it because
then it shows the fact that our
democracy has been side lined as
eisenhower warned us experience
[inaudible].